- Oh hey, yo, that doesn't count.
I got a text.
"Yo, TJ said to call him ASAP."
- Why would he not just call you
if it's an emergency?
- I do something wrong?
- You get all his toilet paper?
(whoosh, squeak)
- Did we pay rent?
- Did you video the wrong Steve again?
Maybe he like, won the lottery.
- You think so?
- [Voiceover] Seven, 16,
nine, five, three, and 30.
- [Short man] What if he
got somebody pregnant?
- Oh shit.
What if he did get somebody pregnant?
Maybe just, like, car trouble.
- Yeah exactly, what if it is car trouble?
(explodes)
- I mean, it's not like he's in jail.
- He's arguing with the neighbors again.
- You got your stupid parties,
where you're up all
night, I don't say shit.
- Damn, did I leave the gas on?
(explodes)
- Maybe you need milk.
- Maybe...
- Bruh, didn't get kidnapped.
Maybe he listened to my mixtape.
(explodes)
When's the last time
you called him anyway?
- Yo, what's up?
You okay?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, just need to know
the Wi-fi password.
- Seriously?
All right, it's uh, syrupsandwich490.
- No, no, that's too long.
Can you just text it to me?